it's really important to Define terms
especially amorphous ones like trust
loyalty love and my definition of Love
is how much I'm willing to give up in
order to maintain something to be
maintain a relationship maintain a
business maintain whatever what am I
willing to sacrifice what that does is
gives you an operational definition of
what love means it also means that you
can compare between two people who do I
love more you may use the word love
because Society will tell you that you
love your brother you love your sister
you love your mother love your cousin
but when you actually think am I really
willing to fly home this weekend to go
see them and the answer is no then
you're actually not willing to sacrifice
that much to keep the relationship
having that as a litmus test for how
much I like or love someone has been
very valuable for me to compare
relationships and so that I could
actually monitor myself and say how much
do I really like this person well how
much am I willing to give up to keep the
relationship and that tells me how much
I really love them